roman abramovich said wednesday he is
selling his english soccer team chelsea
fc and will donate all net proceeds to
victims of russia's war in ukraine this
brings an end to his nearly 20-year
ownership of the club amid political
pressure for the british government to
sanction russian billionaires abramovic
said in a statement he's asked the team
to establish a charitable foundation
where he will donate all net proceeds of
the sale
for the benefit of all victims of the
war in ukraine the billionaire will not
ask for any loans to be repaid appearing
to allude to a 2 billion loan he lent
the club during his ownership his
announcement follows an attempt to
shield his ownership of the club by
handing control of it to the team's
charitable foundation over the weekend
which did not stop multiple members of
parliament from calling for sanctions
against abramovich
despite these calls for now prime
minister boris johnson has resisted
sanctioning oligarchs like abramovic as
of wednesday abramovic's net worth was
12.4 billion dollars down from 13.6
billion dollars on saturday abramovich
purchased chelsea fc for about 190
million dollars in 2003 and the team is
now valued at more than 3 billion
according to forbes estimates
[Music]